un poco más de 300 páginas que detallan
porque el FBI nunca debería haber
lanzado una investigación sobre la
campaña de Donald Trump en 2016 conocida
como crossfire harricane el fiscal
especial John Durham fue nombrado por la
administración Trump en 2019 para
revisar los orígenes de la pesquisa
sobre los vínculos entre Trump y Rusia
dorham afirma que el sesgo del personal
del FBI llevó a una investigación
prematura basándose en las pruebas
reunidas en las múltiples
investigaciones federales exhaustivas y
costosas sobre estos asuntos incluida la
presente investigación ni las fuerzas
del orden estadounidenses ni la
comunidad de inteligencia parecen haber
poseído ninguna prueba real de la
colusión en su poder al inicio de la
investigación del crossfire
pidió al departamento de Justicia que
nombra un funcionario neutral para
supervisar estas investigaciones
políticamente sensibles el informe
señala diferencias en la forma en que el
FBI manejó la investigación sobre Trump
En comparación con otras pesquisas como
las que implicaban a hillary Clinton
pero muchas de las preocupaciones
esbozadas no son nuevas y ya habían sido
publicadas en un informe del Inspector
general del departamento de justicia en
2019 estamos profundamente preocupados
de que se hayan cometido tantos errores
básicos y fundamentales por parte de
tres equipos de investigación separados
elegidos a dedo en una de las
investigaciones más delicadas del FBI en
respuesta al informe de Durham el FBI
dijo que ya ha implementado docenas de
acciones correctivas que han estado en
marcha durante algún tiempo los
hallazgos han proporcionado a Trump
cierta munición mientras Avanza en su
campaña por la reelección en 2024 en
medio de una serie de batallas legales
pero el informe de Durham es en realidad
mucho más suave de lo que muchos
esperaban después de que Trump predijera
una purga generalizada del FBI aunque se
han revelado errores No reveló ningún
nuevo procesamiento ni tampoco incluyó
recomendaciones para futuras reformas de
la oficina Federal de investigación